uh and here from the Israeli government
spokesman Elon Levy who's speaking right
now about the end of the ceasefire let's
listened in front of baying crowds on
their way to the Red Cross like the
Jewish hostages were as Hamas resumes
its war against the Israeli people it
still holds
137 hostages from the October 7th
massacre in addition to four hostages
and misas from before this war those
hostages include two children Ariel and
K bibas aged four and and 10 months
respectively two children Hamas now
claims are dead yesterday the Hamas
monsters released a sick depraved and
utterly Twisted propaganda video of
those poor children's father in
captivity crying about the apparent
deaths of his wife and two darling
children and if anyone thinks that
Israel is going to allow hamas's
sadistic evil to stalk this Earth a day
longer after this war they under
underestimate the power of our Humanity
those 137 hostages still in the Gaza
Strip include 117 males not men because
they include the two little bbus
children and 20 females 126 are Israelis
and 11 are foreign Nationals that
includes eight Thai Nationals one
nepales citizen one Tanzanian and one
French Mexican 10 of the remaining
hostages are aged 75 or older and 56
days day 56 after the October 7th
Massacre there are also still seven
missing
persons thus far Israel's military
pressure on Hamas has succeeded in
securing the release of 110 hostages 86
of them are Israelis 24 are foreign
Nationals there are also two hostages
who were murdered and their bodies
subsequently located by IDF forces
during ground operations in Gaza as
Hamas terminates the hostage release
pause news continues to emerge about its
serial and sadistic abuse of Israeli
hostages in captivity both psychological
torture and physical abuse we now know
from the family of yagil and Yakov aged
12 and 16 respectively that Hamas
drugged our children and branded them
like cattle with Burnes from motorcycle
exhaust pipes in order to identify them
in case they tried to escape and Mia
Shem age 21 her family saying her hand
injury was operated on by a vet Hamas
treated our people worse than animals
and we will put Hamas
down yesterday the Prime Minister met
with our friend US Secretary of State
Anthony blinkin our American Allies have
firmly and vocally supported our right
and obligation of self-defense in
response to the October 7th Massacre and
we remain in full agreement on the need
to continue this campaign to get our
hostages back eliminate Hamas and create
a new reality in Gaza that ensures that
the territory can never again be used to
commit attacks against the Israeli
people like our American Allies we too
want to make every effort and are making
every effort to minimize civilian
casualties in this war that Hamas
declared and to expedite the delivery of
humanitarian Aid the people of Gaza as
of now as Hamas resumes hostilities the
IDF is providing information to
Palestinian civilians in the Gaza Strip
on movement for their safety in the next
stage of the war that Hamas has resumed
including taking note of the evacuation
areas we are determined to continue
thwarting hamas's six strategy of human
Shields having spent the last 16 years
deliberately embedding its military
infrastructure under homes Mall Moses
schools and hospitals and trying to keep
civilians In Harm's Way in order to
evade Justice the IDF has been sending
messages and announcements to the people
of Gaza calling on them to evacuate from
specific areas that are being used by
Hamas for terrorist activities in the
areas of what are of course legitimate
military targets that will be destroyed
in response to the October 7th Massacre
as Hamas continues to vow another
October 7th the IDF has published an
evacuation zone map in Gaza and we urge
uninvolved civilians to evacuate along
the designated routes away from the
specific areas of Hamas Terror activity
for their own safety that interactive
map can be found on the IDF website and
the details are by now familiar to the
people of the Gaza Strip Hamas continues
to make every effort to maximize
civilian
casualties inside Israel and on their
own side we are doing our utmost to
minimize those casualties in ACC the
principles of
inter is choosing to continue fighting
out of densely populated areas that we
are doing our utmost to evacuate we will
continue to uphold all our obligations
under international law and to insist to
the last inch on our rights this war
will end with the end of Hamas we'll now
take your questions thank
you question from uh Jim Williams Zenger
international news service Washington
last night a news conference that uh the
US Secretary of State blinken confirmed
that International Red Cross visiting
the hostages was part of the deal
between Israel Us Egypt and Qatar why
haven't they seen the
hostages we are demanding of course in
accordance with the framework that Hamas
Grant access to the Red Cross to visit
the hostages in accordance with every
principle of of humanity we're talking
about people who were brutally abducted
on October 7th of being held in
communicado some with serious injuries
we saw Mia Shem being operated on by a
vet one hostage returning with bullet
holes still in her bullet wounds still
in her leg 50 uh days after the October
7th Massacre an 84-year-old hostage
brought back in a critical condition
Hamas continues to hold our hostages uh
in communicado without basic
humanitarian Mercy we welcome the call
from the UN Secretary General that the U
that the Red Cross must be granted
access to those hostages immediately and
unconditionally and as we said yesterday
and have been saying consistently we
expect the United Nations and all
International agencies to continue not
not to continue I'm sorry to start
putting pressure on Hamas to give the
Red Cross access to those hostages while
those agencies continue to cover up and
deny hamas's abuse use of protected
humanitarian facilities for military
purposes while those agencies continue
to provide cover for hamas's ongoing and
severe violations of humanitarian law it
is time for that cover up to stop and
for the United Nations to put serious
pressure any pressure on Hamas and its
supporters to Grant the Red Cross access
to those hostages so the
137 remaining hostages in the Gaza Strip
can be given that basic humanitarian
Mercy until they are released
immediately and unconditionally as we
are
demanding uh next question from coach
wein housee Globe Banner in responding
to us pressure what would prevent Israel
committing to allow limited number of
Gaza non-combatants back to the North in
a safe Zone when the north is
secured the northern Gaza Strip at the
moment is still an active war zone the
IDF is continuing with its operations
now to totally eliminate Hamas military
infrastructure and we expect that when
the fighting stop STS and it is safe for
people to be able to return they will
return and we will begin a process of
reconstruction together with the
International Community but critically
this time a process of reconstruction
that ensures that the concrete goes to
people's houses and not to the sorts of
military tunnels that we have been
exposing under the shifa hospital
reconstruction that makes sure pipelines
for water go to connecting water
infrastructure and are not converted
into Rockets to be used against Israeli
civilians as Hamas has proudly
documented in its own propaganda
videos question from Julia Frankle
Associated Press the military appears to
be preparing to evacuate parts of the of
Southern Gaza where are people who are
ordered to evacuate to Southern Gaza
supposed to go even uh given that the
north is nearly uninhabitable and the
specified safe zone of Alm masawi is too
small for thousands evacuees have other
safe zones been developed if so what are
the names of these zones I would refer
you to the most authoritative answer
which is the evacuation zone map that
the IDF has published including the
specific evacuation routes that was
released in a press statement by the IDF
a few hours ago including a link to an
interactive map on their website and I
hope that that will answer your question
satisfactorily question from Howard
goler from Reuters what is your response
to the Biden Administration informing
Israel that Washington will impose Visa
bans in the next few weeks on Israeli
extremist settlers engaged in violence
against Palestinian civilians in the
occupied West Bank we have no comment on
that of course we also firmly condemn
any vigilantism or hooliganism or
attempt by individual extremists to take
the law into their own hands there is
absolutely no room for that and that
must be answered very firmly by Israeli
law
enforcement
is
me we appear to have a problem with our
microphone so I will continue uh like
this do we have any other questions
please yes uh from Indian uh Indian
journalists for tv9 IDF has P published
a map uh showing Gaza as hundreds of
zones that people of Gaza may leave the
specific areas before the strike please
share some details like how it will work
how much time will be given uh to the
local
residents as I hope everyone is familiar
by now uh since the encirclement of Gaza
City in response to the October 7th
Massacre Israel has been facilitating
humanitarian corridors for the people of
Gaza to evacuate to safety those
humanitarian corridors of course
attacked by Hamas terrorists trying to
stop civilians from evacuating in order
to continue using them as human Shields
that is a core part of their strategy
the Israeli Army in Northern Gaza also
put in place uh specific tactical pauses
in order to encourage evacuations that
is what the Israeli Army has been doing
to date in order to facilitate those
evacuations and as the war now resumes
as hostilities resume with hamas's
decision to terminate the hostage
release pause and violate the terms of
the agreement you can see on the IDF
website the map of the specific
evacuation areas and the evacuation
roots and I think the IDF has already
proven in the last few weeks the efforts
that it has been making in order to get
civilians out of Harm's Way it's
important to understand Hamas has a
deliberate strategy of keeping civilians
In Harm's Way so that it can sacrifice
them so that it can Marty them these are
awful words and they are not our words
they are hamas's own words it is a sick
and twisted strategy that violates every
principle of humanitarian law and
humanity and it is a strategy that we
are trying to thwart by getting
civilians out of Harm's Way because this
is not a war against the Palestinians
this is not a war against the people of
Gaza this is a war against Hamas which
launched this war with the October 7th
Massacre and is trying to fight this war
from behind women and children we're
trying to get out of Harm's
Way Hazel Ward AFP we're hearing that
President Herzog left uh the cop talks
uh cop without giving his scheduled
speech uh and explain please can you
explain
why I'm not familiar with that and I
would refer your question to the Press
office at the Office of the President uh
not the government of Israel thank you
these are separate branches of
government question from uh pesak benion
uh according to a Saudi media report
Israel struck a hooti missile UAV Depo
in s yesterday can you confirm or deny
the
report we have no comment on this report
at this
stage okay I think that brings us to a
close okay thank you very much everyone
shabbat shalom and let's hope for a
peaceful and safe weekend thank you very
much